[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في ظل وضع ميداني تتقدم فيه
كتائب المعارضه السوريه على جبهات مختلفه
اوفد النظام وزير داخليته الى موسكو ووزير
دفاعه الى طهران وفي البلدين خرجت تصريحات
تؤكد التعاون في مكافحه ما يوصف بالارهاب
في سوريا نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي نناقشه
في محورين ما هي دلالات افاد النظام
السوري وزيري داخليته ودفاعه الى موسكو
وطهران في هذا
التوقيت كيف يمكن ان تؤثر هذه التحركات
على خيارات النظام في اداره صراعه مع مع
كتائب المعارضه التي تتقدم على جبهات
[موسيقى]
عده الى اين يتجه النظام السوري في ظل
تراجع قواته امام تقدم معارضيه على اكثر
من جبهه وتقدمهم تجاه معاقل انصاره في
الساحل اتجه الى الحليفين الاقرب روسيا
وايران اوفد وزير داخليته محمد الشعار الى
موسكو حيث وقع اتفاقا للتعاون في مكافحه
الارهاب كما اوفد وزير دفاعه فهد جاسم
الفريج الى طهران حيث اكد ونظيره الايراني
مواصله الحرب على ما وصفاه ايضا بالارهاب
لكن تبقى تساؤلات عن حدود قدره روسيا
وايران على دعم النظام السوري وهما تشتبك
في علاقات مع الغرب ذات ابعاد مختلفه
اقتصاديه
وسياسيه ترجح ال كفه لصالح المعارضه فيهرب
جنود الاسد لكن الى اين والسؤال الاكثر
اهميه هو حول خيارات الاسد نفسه وقد اصبحت
المعارضه فعليا على مشارف
اللاذقيه لم يتبقى من ادلب سوى
المسطومة ان قرى العلويين اولئك الذين
جعلهم الاسد وقود حربه على شعبه اصبحت في
دائره التهديد الحقيقي والداهم للمره
الاولى منذ اربع سنوات اهي بوادر الانهيار
العظيم لجيش الرجل المؤشرات تتعاظم وتؤكد
ان ثمه تقدما غير مسبوق في الجبهات كلها
من درعا الى حلب وما بينهما ادلب سقطت جسر
الشغور على اهميتها الاستراتيجيه في ايدي
المعارضه ولاحقا واصل مقات المعارضه
تقدمهم فسيطر على معسكر القرميد وفي
الجنوب تبدو درعا وقراها وجوارها على وشك
السقوط باكملها في ايدي معارضي الاسد في
ظل ذلك يغدو لافتا ان يرسل الاسد وزير
داخليته الى موسكو واللافت اكثر ان يتم
الاعلان عن اتفاقيه بين البلدين تتعلق
بالاسلحه والمدرعات الخاصه بمكافحه الشغب
ما يوحي بان الامر مستتب في سوريا وان
الامر وما فيه مجرد شغب لا يحتاج سوى
مركبات وتقنيات لاحتوائه على ان للصوره
وجها اخر فيما يبدو فالاسد نفسه هرع
لايفاد وزير دفاعه الى طهران قبل ذلك
وجاءت زيارتي وزيره الى موسكو وطهران بعيد
فقدانه جسر الشغور ولاحقا معسكر القرميد
فالامر جلل وربما يكون بحثا عن خيارات
اللحظه الاخيره فطهران بعد لوزان وعاصفه
الحزم وفقا لمتابعين ليست كما كانت قبل
ذلك ازاء الملف السوري وثمه ممانع اصبحوا
يجهرون بالشكوى ويقولون ان على ايران الا
تتراجع امام ما يصفونه بالتقدم التركي
السعودي القطريه ما دفع البعض الى القول
ان الاسد يرغب بتنوع خياراته بالتركيز
اكثر على موسكو على الروس يقومون بما يبدو
ان الايرانيين بداوا بالتراجع عنه ومما
يتردد فان الاسد مستعد للمقايضه على كل شي
ومنح الروس امتيازات اكثر وموطئ قدم اكبر
في المياه الاقليميه السوريه على ان
يقوموا بتامين وحمايته فسيني دوله
العلويين اصبح مهددا بوصول المعارضه الى
مشارف اللاذقيه والحال هذه يتبقى خيار
الاعتصام بدمشق او نقل العاصمه الى اقرب
سفينه حربيه روسيه على
الساحل موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
اوتوا دكتور هشام مروه نائب رئيس الائتلاف
الوطني السوري المعارض ومن موسكو الينا
سوبونينا مديره قسم الشؤون الدوليه في
جريده فريمي الروسيه اهلا بكم سيد اهلا
بكما سيده ايلينا ما دلالات ايفاد
الوزيرين الدفاع والداخليه الى موسكو
وطهران
برايك اولا هذه زيارات هي تاتي في اطار
التعاون ما بين روسيا و سوريا فهناك امور
ثنائيه ما زالت موجوده وروسيا مستعده ان
تساعد سوريا في موضوع مكافه الارهاب
ثانيا الملف السياسي هو موجود
وروسيا الان تنظر الى جنيف
حيث تنعقد في اربعه من ايار
اجتماعات
جنيف على مستوى متوسط وهي اجتماعات تخص
محاولات استئناف مؤتمرات جنيف بمثابه جنيف
الاول وجنيف الثاني روسيا ترحب بهذه
الجهود من قبل الامم المتحده وروسيا تعتقد
بانه على حكومه سوريا ايضا ان توافق على
استمرار الحوار السياسي به الكلام يصلح
لاي وقت لاي توقيت سواء لان جنف بدا في
2012 ثم جرت محاولات لاحقه سمي بجنف اثنين
هذا الكلام عام الان السؤال يطرح
لانه هنالك تقدم للمعارضه في جبهات عده
وهنالك احاديث تقول ان النظام السوري على
وشك ان ان ينهار ولهذا سالناك عن التوقيت
لانه ليس فقط لموسكو في في بلدك لكن ايضا
مع زياره اخرى لطهران في نفس الوقت في نفس
وقت تقدم المعارضه هذا التوقيت كيف
تقرينه هذا ليس الكلام
عام حضرتك تخطئين اذا تقراين بهذا الشكل
الصوره الموجوده الان لانه الان من اخطر
الاوقات في الوضع في سوريا بالفعل
المعارضه تتقدم في بعض المناطق ولكن روسيا
لحتى الان لا تشعر ب بقلق كبير وروسيا
متاكده
بانه من المستحيل ان نرى هناك الحسم
العسكري لاي طرف من الاطراف انا قصتنا
اسمح لي الوقت بالذات حان الوقت لاستئناف
الحوار بشكل الحقيقي ليس فقط على مستوى
لقاءات موسكو هذا ليس كافي اما على مستوى
ج وبمساعده الامم المتحده اسمحي لي ان
اوضح السؤال سؤالي هو انه كلامك يصلح في
اي يوم وفي اي ساعه وفي اي وقت منذ عام
2012 ونحن في عام 2015 موسكو ترحب بالحوار
تتحدث عن جناب هذا ما قصد بالكلام العام
السؤال سؤالنا يطرح في هذا البرنامج اليوم
بالنظر الى التوقيت التوقيت هو ان
المعارضه تقدم المسلحين تقدموا في درعا في
ادلب في حلب لم تحسم هنالك تقدم جسر
الشغور كان له دلاله كبيره هذا ما دعاني
لكي اطرح عليك هذا
السؤال هذه هي قراءتكم انتم انتم تحاولون
تظهر الوضع كانه وزراء من سوريا ياتون الى
كل من موسكو وطهران كانه خوفا من تطور
الاوضاع في سوريا نحن هون لا نشعر نفس
الشعور في موسكو ونرى بانه هذه الزيارات
تاتي في اطار حتى التعاون المعتاد به ما
بين روسيا وسوريا ولكن موضوع استئناف
الحوار هو الان في بالغ الاهميه لانه اذا
المعارضه ت تقدم او تحاول ان تتقدم
فحوار مطلوب في اكثر من اي وقت و
بالمقارنه طيب وصلت فكرتك وهي ليست
ل فقط للتوضيح ليست بقراءتها هو سؤال يطرح
ويمكنه ان يطرح في اي مكان اخر غير
الجزيره ايضا وسحب الان بضيفي من اوتاوا
دكتور هشام مروه نائب رئيس الائتلاف
الوطني السوري المعارض دكتور هل ترى اي
دلاله لتوقيت
الزيارتين ابتداء مساء الخير لك ول الاخوه
المشاهدين وضيفتك الكريمه لا شك يعني اي
متابع لما يجري على الاحداث في سوريا ويجد
هذا التطور للدرام الجاري الان في تحول او
في زياره الى طهران والى موسكو الحليفتين
القويتين الرئيسيتين لنظام الاسد هذا يعكس
وبشكل واضح تماما ان هناك ازمه عسكريه
خانقه يعانيها النظام ادت الانهيارات هنا
وهناك هذه المس مساله ربما ضيفتنا من
موسكو لم تسمع بها حتى الان لكن المساله
مساله وقت المساله فعلا مساله وقت عندما
ان شاء الله تدق يعني اصوات
الثوار قصور او قصر المهاجرين في دمشق
نريد الحقيقه نحن متمسكون ايضا بالحل
السياسي ونريد فعلا ان ان لا تنزف وان لا
تسقط قطره دم سوريه واحده ونريد فعلا ان
يكون هناك مفاوضات للحل السياسي ولكن يبدو
ان النظام هو الذي ادار ظهره لكل
المحاولات بدءا من محاوله الجامعه العربيه
في شهر ايلول 2 2011 وانتهاء ب 2014 كما
تذكرين عندما ذهب وفد المعارضه فاتحا يديه
يقول ليشكل هيئه حكم انتقاليه الان ولنبدا
بعمليه سلام الان ولكن هذه الدعوه لم تجد
عند ممثلي النظام ايه استجابه مصرون على
الحل العسكري كما صرحت بذلك بثينه شعبان
خلال ذلك اللقاء خلال حتى خلال المفاوضات
كان وفد النظام يؤكد على ان الحل العسكري
هو المخرج الوحيد وان التطورات ميدانيه
على الارض تؤثر على ما يجري في جنيف في
ذلك الوقت ونقول الان وعلى الرغم من تقدم
المعارضه هنا وهناك نقول الدعوه الى الحل
السياسي مفتوحه بشار الاسد وحلفائه عليهم
ان يفهموا ان الحل العسكري لن يكون ممكنا
في سوريا بتقدم الثوار الحل العسكري ق ق
يكون انت الان تقول دكتور انت قد يكون
الحل العسكري باتجاه اخر طيب انت كائ الاف
تقول ذلك لكن هل
المسلحون المعار او ما يسمى بالمعارضه
المسلحه على اختلاف فصائلها وتوجهاتها
والتي تقدمت هل هي بوارد ان تقول دعونا
نتحاور الان ونجد حلا
سلميا ما اريد توضيحه في هذه النقطه اننا
على تواصل مع مع الفصائل بشكل حقيقي هذا
امر منتهي من ايام كان هناك مؤتمر تشاوري
للفصائل مع قياده الائتلاف بالاعضاء من
الائتلاف كانت الروح الايجابيه موجوده
كانت الفصائل حاضره ما يؤكد ان الاخوه
المقاتلين من من فصائل الجيش الحر والفص
وجيش الفتح الذين يحققون انتصارات في
الشمال والجنوب ما يؤكد حرصهم على الحل
السياسي وعلى حر على حقن دماء السوريين
انهم لم يرتكبوا اطلاقا ايه مخالفه لاي
نظام دولي في هذه لقوانين الدوليه في هذه
الفتوحات وفي هذه المعارك التي جرت ما
الذي يعكس هذا لم يتعرضوا لاحد دور كيف
كيف لم يتعرضوا لاحد هنالك فيديوهات تشير
الى ارتكابات ارتكبتها المعارضه مثلها مثل
ما تقولون ان النظام ارتكبه وهنالك منظمات
يومان رايتس وتش وغيرها وعفو دوليه ذكرت
ذكرت المعارضه المسلحه في
تقاريرها هل ذكرتها في هذه المره ام
ذكرتها في مرات سابقه نرجو ان لا يكون
الخلط عندما اعلنت قوات جيش الفتح التي
دخلت ادلب انه من عاد الى وظيفته فهو امن
وانه من جلس في بيته فهو امن وانه من
اعتزل حتى من هؤلاء الذين تورطوا بجرائم
فهو امن اليست رساله من هؤلاء المقاتلين
على رغبتهم بحقن دماء السوريين فعلا
الثوار المقاتلون جيش الفتح كلنا حريصون
على دماء كل السوريين كل اخواننا السوريين
في كل سوريا ودعوتنا موجهه الى هؤلاء
الذين ما زالوا محسوبين على النظام ان
يمارسوا دورهم الو
في انقاذ سوريا والخلاص من الاس طيب ساده
الينا اذا كانت كما تقولين موسكو حريصه
على ان على ان يكون هنالك حل سلمي كما
ذكرتي وليس عسكري وعلى تشجيع الحوار لماذا
لا تبادر على التحاور مع جميع اطياف
المعارضه وليس طرف واحد كان هنالك محاولات
معه في موسكو ولكن بقيه المعارضه والفصائل
المسلحه لم تقبل به اذا لماذا لا تاخذ
بالاعتبار موسكو ان هنالك اخرون ينبغي
ربما التحاور معهم حتى فعلا يكون هنالك
تاثير ايجابي وفعلي على الارض
للحوار ولكن هذا السؤال هو سؤال غريب لانه
من المعروف انه روسيا قبل لقاء موسكو
الاول وقبل لقاء موسكو الثاني وجهت دعوات
لكل اطراف المعارضه السوريه باستثناء
جماعات ارهابيه مثل داعش وروسيا عده مرات
اظهرت استعدادها
بقبول لم اتحدث عن دعوات وشكليات سيده
النا لم اتحدث عن دعوات وشكليات هذا هذا
يبقى فقط دعوات وشكليات يعني هم لا
ينتظرون ان ت تذك اسمهم هم يريدون اجنده
واضحه على اساسها يقبلون بالذهاب
لمناقشتها يعني مثلا كان من ضمن شروطهم ان
يناقش مصير الاسد هل كانت موسكو ب هل
موسكو الان مثلا تقبل بان يجري حوار بدون
الاسد
شخصيا روسيا تقول انه ليست هناك شروط
مسبقه والامم المتحده د مستوره يقول نفس
الشيء هذا مضحك بدا الحوار اعتمادا على
شروط مسبقه لانه هدف الحوار هو التوصل الى
التفوق وروسيا بالفعل وجهت دعوات هن ما
قبلوها روسيا تقول انه نحن مستعدين ان
نعمل على اجنده مستعدين ان نعمل عليها في
موسكو في جنف في اي مكان اخر اقبلوا هذا
المقترح ولكن قبل حضرتك طرحتي السؤال مهم
جدا هو هل المعارضه نفسها هي الان تتقدم
في بعض المناطق ولكن ما هدفها هل هي بدها
حسم عسكري او لا هي بدها تجمع الاوراق من
ربما ربما الان من يسمعك سيده ايلينا
واضحه فكرتك لكن دعيني ان اوضح السؤال لك
انه عندما تقولين وجهنا دعوات وهم من
رفضوا هم لم يرفضوا هكذا
يعني للا شيء رفضوا لانه هنالك اتهام
لروسيا بانها منحازه لطرف دون اخر منحازه
للنظام وتزوده بالسلاح عليها ان ت تكون
اكثر حياديه واكثر سلميه فعلا
عبر عدم تز طرف بالسلاح والوقوف معه
وتدريب
عناصره وفيما الطرف الاخر يجري الانحياز
ضده هذا هذا هكذا ينظرون الى موسكو
المعارضه ولهذا ربما لم
يلبوا هم هكذا ينظرون هي مشكلتهم هني
روسيا تقول انه هي لا تريد ان تحتكر
العمليه التفاوضيه روسيا تقول اذا انتم
تعتبرنا من حزين او شيء من هذا النوع وهذا
ليس صحيح فتفضلوا اذهب الى ج كيف لس صحيح
اذهبوا في نهايه المط الوزير كان عندكم
وزير الداخليه كان عندكم وزودت موه يعني ب
عرفتموه على عمل قوات الردع السريع في
وزاره الداخليه مدرعات قوات خاصه روسيه
واساليب مكافحه الشغب وكان وكان سوريا
الان تعاني فقط من بعض
الشغب وروسيا تساعدها على مكافحه الشغب
وتقولين هذا ليس انحيازا او ليس نظره
محدده وضيقه لما يجري في
سوريا روسيا اتسق بالحكومه السوريه في
موضوع مكافه الارهاب كما كانت واثقه
بحكومه سوريا بموضوع القضاء على الاسلحه
الكيمياويه ولكن روسيا تفهم بانه نجاح في
مكافحه الارهاب ممكن ان يتم اعتمادا على
كل القوه المعتدله في سوريا فمن اجل هذا
الشيء لابد من بدل حوار ما بين المعارضه
المعتدله وممثلي الحكومه السوريه هل
تعتبرين دكتور هشام معارضه معتدله سيده
الينا الان معنا الضيف معك دكتور هشام هل
تعتبرونه معارضه
معتدله روسيا عده مرات دعت الائتلاف
بالاشخاص وكمم ازمه الى روسيا وقبلنا
الفوض من الائتلاف
معرات حت الائتلاف معارضه معتدله بالنسبه
اليك طيب دكتور هشام م مروه انتم معارضه
معتدله ووجه اليكم دعوات وانتم لا تقبلون
اذا ما الضير من ان يذهب النظام طالما هو
يلبي يذهب وز وزير الداخليه الى هناك انتم
مقصرون يعني اسمحي لي ابتداء ان اذكر
ضيفتك الكريمه وان اذكر امامكم ان نتائج
ما جرى في موسكو في المره الاولى والمره
الثانيه كانت كارثيه بالمعنى الانساني
عندما تعرض بشار الجعفري للوفد بالتهديد
وب اساءه و يعني نحن نعلم تماما ان حوارا
بهذه الصوره وفي موسكو ماذا يعني بالنسبه
للاسد ولذلك اتخذ الائتلاف موقفا واضحا
بيقول اننا نعتذر عن هذا اللقاء لان هذا
اللقاء بالتاكيد ليس لا يمتلك
اجنده تؤكد جديه هذا اللقاء من اجل الوصول
الى حل اجراءات بناء الثقه التي طلبها
الائتلاف لم يتقدم النظام باي شيء يؤكد
رغبته بالحل
هم يريدون حقيقه ان ياتوا بالمعارضه لشكل
من الاشكال رساله لمجتمع الدولي لا تدعموا
المعارضه العسكريه الان لا تضعوا المعارضه
الثوريه الان اعطوا فرصه للحل السياسي هذا
الوقت يستفيد منه الاسد وزبانيته وحلفائه
من اجل ضرب السوريين ومزيد من القتل في
سوريا لن نقبل بان نكون بوابه لاعطاء
الاسد وقتا من اجل قتل ابنائنا واخواننا
وهدم بلداننا وتدمير بيوتنا من اجل ذلك لم
تذهب المعارضه لان ما يجري في موسكو وما
كان يجري هنا وهناك لم نكن نعتبره دعوه
جديه واطار جديا لبدا عمليات حل سياسي
الان نحن هناك توجه في جنيف تقوده الامم
المتحده على الرغم من اننا لا نتظر الكثير
من ذلك وافقنا على ان نذهب حرصنا على يعني
كلمه اخيره فقط عندما تكون الداعيه الامم
المتحده وعندما يكون هناك جهات دوليه نشعر
بجديه نتقدم خطوه الى الامام بعد الفاصل
طيب بعد الفاصل نتحدث اككثر عن هذا
الموضوع وعن بالتحديد ايضا الزياره الى
ايران معك
ضيفنا دكتور مرو وسيده الينا اعود بعده
بعد هذا الفاصل ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد سيده الينا مباشره
اليك كيف ترى موسكو الان
مستقبل النظام السوري في ظل التطورات
الميدانيه على
الارض
روسيا تهتم بمستقبل
سوريا اما موضوع النظام والحكومه ف الان
حتى امريكان واوروبي فهموا انه في سوريا
من الضروري اجراء الاصلاحات السياسيه طيب
هذا فهمها من زمان ولكن من الضروري الحفاظ
على مؤسسات الوله مصير
العراق هو مبكي جدا و هذا الشيء لن يتكرر
في سوريا ففي من اجل هذا من الممكن
التعاون ما بين الحكومه ايضا والمعارضه
المعتدله وللاسف اريد ان اقول لضيفك
الكريم
انه الموضوع ليس فقط في المعارضه السوريه
المشكله في من وراء هذه المعارضه ما هي
اهداف السعوديه ما هي اهداف قطر وتركيا
وبالاخير امريكا حتى هذه هي ام
سذا سيره امر على سيره امريكا كما ذكرتي
روبرت فورد تعرفين كان سفيرا في سوريا هو
توقع انهيارا للنظام السوري اذا كانت
وغيره توقع ايضا اذا كانت هذه
التوقعات قريبه او لها اي احتمال من مصلحه
موسكو ان ان تبقى على نفس السياسه منذ ان
بدات المشكله في
سوريا راد هذا اذا هون ليس في محله ليش
لانه سياسه امريكا في عهد باراك اوباما هي
سياسه متناقضه جدا منذ اسبوعين تقريبا جون
كيري كان يقول بانه من الممكن التعاون مع
اسد في موضوع مكافحه الارهاب الان السفير
السابق يقول شيئا اخر
ف نحن في روسيا نفهم انه الان ليست امريكا
تقرر ما ستفعله المعارضه في الم
اما السعوديه وقطر وتركيا لاث دول هذه
ممكن ان تضغط على المعارضه لكي تبدا
الحوار السياسي طيب دكتور هشام الان هذه
التحركات افاد الوزيرين برايك كيف يمكن ان
يؤثر على
اداره النظام السوري للصراع على الارض في
ظل تطورات الميدانيه التي
تعلمها يعني بكل تاكيد
ما النظام الان من خلال استنجاده وصرخات
الاستغاثه التي وجهها الى موسكو والى
طهران هو فعلا يريد دعوتهم الى تطبيق
الاتفاقيات التي سبق ان وقعوها معه او مع
ابيه من اجل ذلك هذه هي وهذه الرساله
مفهومه بالنسبه للثوار
ومقاتلين من من الثوار على الارض ولكن ما
اريد قوله في هذه في هذه في هذا المجال ان
الثوار عندما انطلقوا كانوا يعرفون ان
الاسد تحالفات ومعاهدات و مع ذلك انطلقوا
الثوار عندما انطلقوا لم يستثنوا احدا لا
من اصدقاء سوريا الذين بلغوا 114 دوله
الان ولا ولا حتى من خصوم من من من خصومهم
الذين هم حلفاء النظام ايضا قرار المعارضه
واريد ان يكون واضحا عندما تتقاطع قرارات
المعارضه مع دعم حقيقي من الدول الشقيقه
والصديقه ففعلا من الممكن ان يكون هناك
تعاون على انتاج قرار مشترك اما اطلاقا لن
يكون قرار المعارضه مرتهنا لاحد الا لما
تقرره مصلحه الثوره على الارض وهذا فعلا
ما نسمعه من الاخوه في السعوديه وفي ق وفي
تركيا و الدول الدا الدول التي معروفه
التي تدع تدعم المعارضه الان يعني هل هي
جمعيه خيريه هنالك تسليح جرى للمعارضه
ايضا والمعارضه استغاثت اكثر من مره
بالبلدان التي تسميها صديقه لها وبالتالي
ربما من العدل ان نقول ان لكل من الجهتين
لكل من الطرفين من
يدعمه يعني هذ هذه مساله مختلفه انا اتحدث
عن القرار قرار الثوار قرار وطني بامتياز
لا يمكن ان يرتهن لاحد الا لمصلحه الثوره
الا لمصلحه سوريا الى تحقيق اهداف الثوره
في اقامه دوله العدل والحريه والمواطنه
هذا ما يتطلع عليه الثوار والاخوه في
الدول الشقيقه الداعمه فعلا متفقون معنا
في هذا الامر قد يكون هناك تقاطع في تطور
وضع اقليمي عندما استطاع الاسد ان يستجلب
قوى الشر الداعمه له فاصبح هناك خطر
اقليمي على كل قوى على كل دول المنطقه م
وم الم المفترض ان يكون هناك تنسيق باتجاه
اخر هل تتخيلين عندما يكون هناك خطر ازمه
طائفيه في سوريا ازمه طائفيه في المنطقه
ان تقف دول منطقه متفرجه امام هذه المساله
شكرا دكتور هشام للاسف انتهى الوقت شكرا
لك دكتور هشام رو نائب رئيس الائتلاف
الوطني السوري المعارض من اوتاوا واشكر
موسكو الينا سوبونينا مديره قسم الشؤون
الدوليه في جريده فريما الروسيه الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ا